nous avons trouvé beaucoup de choses qui
vont dans un sens que nous souhaitons
nous souhaitons que la france se
réforment souhaitons le succès du
gouvernement parce que ça serait le
succès de
pays ça serait bien pour ses habitants
donc nous sommes favorables pour
accompagner beaucoup de ces mesures il
ya aussi d'interrogations sur un certain
de l'endroit en particulier sur la
réforme institutionnelle et puis sur le
sujet territoriaux mais là et on nous
dit que le premier vise à apporter des
compléments d'informations et de
précisions demain matin dans un groupe
centriste madame on donne jamais de
consigne de vote
chaque sénateur se déterminent librement
à l'heure où je vous parle puisque et
encore des réflexions en cours
une bonne partie de
nos sénateurs au trou favorablement les
propositions du gouvernement et la
plupart
un
ça pue terrain